let's say we have two entrepreneurs and
they are both interested in buying a
pizzeria and eventually turning it into
a public company so let's compare the
two so let me draw a dividing line here
between
the first and the second entrepreneurs
and they're actually going to buy
identical assets so they're going to buy
a pizzeria with the ovens inside of them
and the same amount of cash in the cash
register everything they need to operate
the pizzeria and it's and there may be
in identical locations maybe right next
to each other at the same intersection
or across the street from each other
so it's the same asset
let me draw that out i don't want to
draw this box
so that's the asset
and it costs a hundred thousand dollars
that includes the building it includes
the uh the the oven it includes the the
places where where the customers come
sit and even includes the cash needed to
operate the business so you need some
cash to pay vendors just to get started
and to pay for things like doe and to
have some money in the cash register and
to have a little bit of a bank account
things like that so that's all inclusive
all of the assets
needed to start the the the firm the the
pizzeria so this is the assets
and they both buy identical assets let
me copy and paste that c
okay
let's see copy and paste there you go
they buy identical assets now the first
entrepreneur he's very conservative and
he's been saving his whole life to do
this so he actually has a hundred
thousand dollars of cash to buy his
pizzeria so he buys it out right so he
owns it outright so all of the hundred
thousand dollar of asset value is
actually his equity
i'm doing equity in a different color
it's all his equity
so that's all his equity
this guy here maybe he's a little bit
earlier in his career he just is not as
good at saving money so he has to he
doesn't have quite a hundred thousand
dollars he actually only has ten
thousand dollars in his pocket
but he's a smooth talker
he's a smooth stalker so he goes to the
local bank and say hey i have this great
idea for let me write this down 10 000
of equity that's what he has but he
tells the the guy at the bank and he
buys them lunch he says i have this
great idea for a pizzeria and they agree
to give him not just 90 000. this guy
he's a little ambitious too he thinks
not just besides a pizzeria in the name
of the pizzeria he's going to borrow
some money and then maybe invest that in
stocks or something
so he gets a sweetheart deal on on the
loan and he's able to actually borrow a
little bit more than what he even needs
he only needs a 90k but let's say he
borrows 100k
so he borrows a hundred thousand dollars
of debt
a hundred thousand dollars of debt
that's right there
a hundred thousand of debt
100k of
debt and so he has a hundred ten
thousand dollars to play with he buys a
hundred thousand dollar pizzeria and
then he has another ten thousand dollars
left over to do with what he wants and
he he puts it in the pizzeria's name
in the pizzeria's bank account because
he has to show the bank that's going
towards the pizzeria but his real intent
is to maybe gamble with it on the side
and the pizzeria's name and maybe invest
in stocks or speculate on on pork belly
futures or something like that but let's
just for algebra versus it for for all
intents and purposes it's it's cash
right and so they go off and they start
their pizzeria and so let's see what
happens
so let's look at them over the course of
let's look at on the course of of of one
year
of one year so let's say revenue
it's revenue
so let's say the first year they're
identical they both make 100k in revenue
100k
100k let's say their cost of goods sold
is roughly 50 percent of that so let's
say it's
50k
i'll put a minus there because it's an
expense minus 50k
so they're both of their gross profit
is 50k
50k
and then their sg a is the same and if
you've watched the video on if you watch
the video on
depreciation and amortization this might
even include the depreciation on some of
the physical assets they bought or maybe
the amortization on the rights to the
name you know super pizzeria in either
case maybe they're both the brands are
identical
so that's let's say that's another 20k
minus 20k
minus 20k so far they look very very
identical and that's because they
they have the same exact asset
so their operating profit
operating profit
50 minus 20 is 30k 50 minus 20 is 30k
and now we'll start to see a little
difference and and this goes back to the
very first video we saw if you have an
identical asset if the asset is being
managed identically which it is in this
case they will generate an identical
amount of operating profit when i talk
about the asset i'm talking about the
only the operating assets right this guy
has some non-operating assets although
it's officially part of the company he
doesn't need it to operate this is cash
above and beyond what's needed in the
cash register and
you know we could have we might have a
little bit of cash here in this asset
that's needed for the cash register and
for i'll teach you more about working
capital but in order to pay vendors and
things like this this is a cash and
above and beyond what's necessary this
guy has a little bit of cash just to
operate the business he just doesn't
have this gambling cash out here
so
now we add an interesting line
non-operating income so
non-op
income
this guy doesn't make anything he's not
gambling this guy is pretty good with
his ten thousand dollars of speculation
cash she makes let's say twenty percent
on it in this first year so he makes two
thousand dollars
and then we have interest expense
interest expense this guy has no debt
very prudent he has no interest so his
pre-tax
pre-tax income
is thirty thousand dollars this guy
he does have interest right
let's say on that hundred thousand
dollars of debt uh he got a really good
deal let's say that the fed thought that
he was systemically important to the
future of our financial system so he
gave them a sweetheart i don't know two
percent debt deal just because he was
afraid that if if if if this pizzeria
were to fail it would bring down the
entire financial system
so given that so two percent on a
hundred thousand dollar debt that's two
thousand of that a year so minus two
thousand i'll make it a little bit more
realistic let's say it's four percent
let's say it's i'll make it even more
let's say it's five percent
five percent
five percent debt
on the so five percent on a hundred
thousand dollars is 5k per year in
interest so that's his interest expense
let me write that this interest this was
non-op
non-op income this was operating profit
just to see just you just have to carry
the lines over
and so his pre-tax income
pre-tax is now 30 plus two minus five is
27 k
they both pay 30
in taxes
taxes
and so this guy is paying ten thousand
dollars
or let's say well actually nine thousand
dollars would be thirty percent and this
guy thirty percent of
227 so let's see taxes
see it's three six thousand plus it's
eight thousand one hundred
minus eight thousand one hundred is that
right
yeah that's nine thousand and then if
you have three thousand less you should
be 900 less yep that's right and so
we're finally at the net income line
net income
net income
this guy makes 21k
this guy makes
what is this this is
nineteen thousand
[Music]
nine eighteen thousand nine hundred
thousand
net income and of course the difference
is is is the money that he had to spend
on tax on not just on on interest
expense right if you net out all of his
little financial engineering he had to
pay three thousand more in interest
if you net out his profit he made on his
little cash bets on his side bets and
and that
was able to be a tax deduction so the
actual effect ends up being two thousand
one hundred right which essentially
three thousand dollars at a thirty
percent tax rate
so fair enough that's not what i want to
do here i don't want to focus too much
on the interest
the tax savings on interest what i want
to do here is focus on valuation and see
whether the price to earnings ratio
holds up to scrutiny in this situation
where you have an identical asset but
very different capital structures
so let's say they both have ten thousand
shares
shares
i'll arbitrarily switch colors ten
thousand
ten thousand shares
so eps this guy made twenty one thousand
dollars this year divided by ten
thousand shares is two dollars and ten
per share
this guy eighteen thousand nine hundred
divided by ten thousand is a dollar
eighty nine per share and let's say you
know for all and we could have modeled
out their income statements further and
actually this guy even if the top line
even if the revenue grew the same and on
the operating profit grew the same
because of his leverage he would
actually grow a little bit faster i'll
do another video on how that works with
leverage but let's say that someone
looks at this they say okay it's the
same business everything and if anything
this guy is growing a little bit faster
because he's got that leverage that
extra juice from from the financials
from the capital structure he's got so
they both deserve at least a price to
earnings of 10.
right so you say they both deserve a
price to earnings of 10. so 10 price to
earnings you'd say i'm willing to pay 21
for this guy and i'm willing to pay 18
and 90 cents for this guy
now why does that what does that result
in their valuation or in terms of their
market cap so in this guy's case market
cap
21 times twenty one thousand times ten
thousand shares means that you are
ascribing a see twenty one times ten
you're saying that the equity in this
company is worth two hundred and ten
thousand dollars
two hundred and ten thousand dollars in
this case you're saying that the equity
in this company is worth
189
000
right so this one's worth a little bit
more because it's earning a little bit
more money or you might you know i don't
want to complicate it but you might be
willing to pay a higher multiple here so
something very interesting is happening
by applying the same price to earnings
we're saying that the market value of
this equity
is two hundred and ten thousand dollars
while the market value of this equity
is oh is it 189
000
189 000
is that the right number yeah 189 000
right
something doesn't seem to make sense
this guy put up a hundred thousand
dollars and sure they invested it and
did all that so now the market's willing
to say hey you know what this is a
pretty profitable business more
profitable than most you're making good
uh margins and i'll do a bunch of videos
on margins in the future we're willing
to say that it's the market value of
your equity is two hundred ten thousand
dollars which implicitly means that the
market value of this asset
is two hundred and ten thousand dollars
right if they're saying this is worth
two hundred thousand two hundred ten
that's because this must be worth 210
but if you look here by pricing by
giving the same price to earnings
because they're the same business and
maybe this guy's even growing faster so
they're either being conservative by
only giving this guy a 10 price to
earnings
you get a 189 000 market cap for this
equity which all of a sudden this guy
only put in 10k and people are saying
it's worth 189 and if this is worth 189
if if this little fraction right here is
189
then it implies what about this asset
what does it imply about the value of
that asset you have 189 000 is the value
of this equity
the value of this debt is a hundred
thousand so the market is saying the
right hand side of the balance sheet is
what is a 189 plus a hundred thousand
it's
289 000
and let's say this cash is still it's
still cash it's worth ten thousand
dollars so if you subtract it out the
market is saying this is
289 minus this 10 279
000
so something is very bizarre right here
that the market is just because of how
this guy has capitalized his company if
they just a price a superficial price to
earnings of 10 to both companies
it's willing to say that this asset is
worth 279 000 and this assets only worth
210 000
even though they're identical assets
so i've already used more than enough
time on this video so i'll let you
ponder that a little bit and in the next
video i'll show you that the reason why
this is kind of breaking down is because
a price to earnings ratio does break
down to a certain degree when you start
comparing things with different capital
structures and there will and in the
next video i'll introduce you other ways
of comparing things with different
capital structures or essentially
deleveraging them that when you just
talk about price to earnings or market
capitalization right when you just
looked at market capitalization it
looked okay oh there's similar
businesses this one's worth a little bit
more because this one has debt but then
when you actually back out the implicit
value of the asset all of a sudden you
realize that you're really overpaying
for this asset so think about that a
little bit what's kind of the conundrum
here what what what what what went wrong
and the next video will i'll give you
some tools to actually do this right